hello and welcome to dear Android the
show previously known as Android
developer office hours
we got a bit tired of developers always
trying to show us off by asking us
questions we couldn't answer every week
so we just try to decided to try a new
format for a change
we'll be selecting the best Android
application development questions from
across the internet including Google+
and answer them for you here on YouTube
if you're watching us live which is
every Wednesday at 2 p.m. Pacific we'll
be hanging around for a few minutes
after each episode to answer any
questions about this or about the
current episode so with that other way
let's go ahead and move on to this
week's question which comes from Dan CEO
on Stack Overflow whose user from Poland
he asks if I have a custom service that
I'm broadcasting via Bonjour and that
I'd like to either you know broadcast or
discover using Wi-Fi or Bluetooth is
this possible on Android to answer this
question we have Alex Lucas who's a
member of our Android developer
relations team who wrote many of the
doctors many of the docs about both
network service discovery and Wi-Fi on
our developer site Alex could you help
us answer this question absolutely so to
break the question into two subparts
will Bonjour
like services work on Bluetooth and will
they work on Wi-Fi the answer is yes on
Wi-Fi no on bluetooth thank you for
tuning in that's our show it's EOCs bye
so we should actually probably answer
this question in a little bit more
detail but to start with the bluetooth
part bluetooth is a really great
protocol for lots of device to device
applications like streaming music or or
communicating with heart rate monitors
but on Android it does not actually
support TCP so what that means is you
cannot create a TCP socket and connect
to it over Bluetooth to other devices
because network service discovery or at
least the Android implementation of
network service discovery run over TCP
this creates a fundamental and
compatibility between Bluetooth and TCP
that said it does actually work over
Wi-Fi all right
we go into a bit more detail let's give
into the background about what exactly
NSD is so NSD is network service
discovery which is androids
implementation of multicast DNS using
the DNS SD so DNS service discovery
protocol and what this does is it allows
applications to broadcast to their
existence on the local network along
with connection details for that
application to any other devices in the
same proximity which would be any other
devices again on the same local network
so this is useful for things like social
applications games or even network
services like printers or web servers so
that's where you can find out what
devices are nearby
when MSD broadcasts this information
over the network there's four
fundamental pieces of information it's
going to send over one of them is the
device identifier the device identifier
is often going to be either the user's
name or the device host name another
item is going to be the service name the
service name is often going to be the
name of the application for instance if
you have a game called replica Island
that you want to play with other users
over the network and replica Island has
a network service discovery built in the
service name is probably going to be
something like replica Island another
item is going to be the host address
which you don't actually have to enter
yourself a runtime android will just
figure that out for you and send that
along in the MSD packets the final item
is going to be the port and I want to do
make a certain special note about the
port which is that for for mobile
applications the easiest thing to do
when you're designing the game or the
application is not actually to pick your
own port at runtime or hard code one in
what you want to do is get a server
socket and set it to port 0 and what
that's going to do is it's going to tell
the android framework just give me
whatever port is available on the system
when the server socket returns the port
number to you you then enter that port
number into the network service
discovery broadcasts the handy thing
about this is that if you for instance
had decided that you wanted port 53 to
be the one your application runs on and
some other application developers
decided that they wanted port 53 is the
one that their application
there would never be a conflict and
there would never be an issue where
these are had to choose between your
application or someone else's
application running at any given time
this is nice an effect it means you
don't you have to request or reserve
report from the IAEA right now you do
still have to go and register your
service name but it's as simple as just
filling out a simple form and the
chances there being a conflict are
pretty much non-existent yeah very small
you don't actually need the I in a
reservation for when you're doing
internal testing but as soon as you let
your application out onto the Internet
to roam free it's a really good idea to
get a registry yes it's just good
practice yeah all right now we talked a
bit earlier about Bluetooth and even
though you can't use an SD on Bluetooth
there's another answer that we want to
give you a better answer and that's
called Wi-Fi direct Wi-Fi direct is a
peer-to-peer version of Wi-Fi so unless
devices communicate with one another
without having to go through an access
point this provides many of the same
benefits as Bluetooth device device
connections but with the advantages of
Wi-Fi which means increased speed and
increased range this is available on
devices running Android for our above
that space Cream Sandwich and if you
happen to be running Android 4.1
jellybean
you also get service discovery now
unlike the traditional case of network
service discovery which we just
addressed Wi-Fi direct service discovery
will work even when you're not connected
to a network so think about that for a
second
devices running your application nearby
can be detected even if they're not
connected to the same network as you
that's pretty cool yeah what uh my
favorite thing about that what that
basically means is if you're in a movie
theater waiting for the previews to
start let's say you you know gone to the
midnight showing or something like that
you have an hour to kill you can open up
the application and see who else in the
feeder or online is playing the same
game you are and connect to them and
play a game having no idea who they are
it's physical proximity right physical
proximity which is awesome because you
know that the way that the movie theater
is not going to have a Wi-Fi network
there and they're there probably a lot
of them these days actually are designed
to block incoming calls and signals and
stuff
yeah but please don't use that excuse to
play the game right during the movie
right don't play during the movie
there's lots of helpful pretties they
tell you that's just a bad idea and it's
rude there would be a bright screen and
in front of the people behind you and
we're not suggesting that but when you
have time to kill in line or before the
previews knock yourself out
now we do want to point out that it's so
important to implement network service
discovery for when you're connected to a
network there's a couple reasons for
this one of them is that Wi-Fi direct is
not going to work at all when you're
connected to a network because of the
way the underlying technology works
either connected to a network or you're
surfing around for Wi-Fi direct devices
the other item is that there are a lot
of services and hardware that broadcast
services that are designed to be
discovered on a network examples of this
are network cameras and network printers
now most companies will not set up their
network printers to be Wi-Fi direct
accessible because that means anyone who
is within physical proximity who didn't
necessarily have permission to use that
printer could print out whatever they
wanted so the so being on the network
and requiring the user to be on the
network provides a a sort of permission
system or just a small layer of security
so really your best option is to
implement both Wi-Fi direct and NST and
that way your application will have the
best of both worlds and increase the
chances of your users being able to
connect to each other no matter what
circumstance in order to use Wi-Fi
direct service discovery the the
necessary class that you want to use is
Wi-Fi p2p manager which provides an
implementation of DNS SD similar to the
way standard NSD does for more
information about how to actually
implement network service discovery and
service discovery over a Wi-Fi direct we
have a training class available at
developer.android.com slash training and
we really recommend you go there and
read through the tutorial we also
provide some sample code and and it
walks you through a real-world example
of how to implement the this
functionality in a pre-existing
application and
you have any questions about either NSD
or Wi-Fi direct join us via hangout
after the live broadcast
we're will be able to help answer those
questions for you right and if you have
any questions for next week's broadcast
post them to Stack Overflow or send them
to us via Android developers at Google+
and we'll pick the best of them for next
week's podcast alright and with that
we'll see you all next week thanks for
joining us
bye guys